and what sort of things do you think in
your personality or maybe in your
co-founders personalities made you guys
so successful at the beginning when I
look back at that I really think it was
I mean it was first of all it was it was
a lot of hard work it was it was a lot
of luck frankly I think we worked a lot
on our communication but more than
anything else it was it was hustle and
it was the willingness and the ability
to get back up each time we stumbled
every entrepreneur goes through some
great highs hopefully and and some real
low lows and when you're working whether
it's alone or with somebody else you
know the ones who are successful are the
ones who are able to stand up after
falling over and dust themselves off
learn what they needed to from it and I
think what I just talked about was an
example of that where you could see
actually when you look back at our
progress how we were learning that
lesson the hard way it probably took us
way too long but we learned it and you
got there yeah we got there so what
sorts of skills do you think are really
important for entrepreneurs to have at
the outset I'm gonna just pick two
things the first one is resilience just
being able to bounce back after
something doesn't go your way you have
to get really comfortable hearing the
word know and as a small company that
nobody knows about you're gonna hear it
an awful lot and the second one is I
think the willingness to step outside of
whatever room it is that you're in and
maybe this is my my maybe this is
motivated by the fact that I come at
this from an engineering perspective
where the easy part and the fun part is
writing code I mean I was building
something
but that never that was never useful to
do that until I had built a real
understanding of what the customer
wanted and that doesn't happen until you
get outside of your room and start
talking to people and so I think
developing those two skills is more
important than anything else at the
outset so what's one thing that you wish
you would have known before getting
study with Optimizely
you know when we started our
entrepreneurial journey we started
actually working on something completely
different and we we built an education
platform for young kids called carrot
sticks had nothing to do with what we
ended up working on it I think when I
look back at that time what strikes me
is how much time we spent working on
things that didn't actually end up
mattering you know we spent a lot of
time building things that nobody
heard about because we didn't spend
enough time getting to know our
customers and we struggled for a year
but frankly without salaries and and
that was a pretty difficult time and I
think during that year we had to really
erase what we thought we knew about
starting companies and really learn how
to probe and understand the customers
that we were trying to serve and you can
see that in our first company carrot
sticks it took us about six months
before we earned a dollar doing what we
were doing with our second company which
I won't even go into I took about a
month and a half so you can see our
learning scale shrunk and then with
optimize that we actually were able to
earn money on day one before we'd
written any code and I think that's a
signal for first of all the fact that
we've gotten better at understanding our
customers but also for how skeptical
we've gotten of our own ideas and that
we weren't even willing to work on
something unless we were able to prove
that it was something people wanted
enough to pay for